[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans europe
hebdo au programme aujourd'hui l'espagne
tout le pays est en campagne élections
européennes législatives locales
également le parti socialiste espère
rester au pouvoir mais la montée de
l'extrême droite est en train de
bouleverser les équilibres politiques on
en débattra avec nos invités
dans la seconde partie de l'émission
mais d'abord ce sujet au coeur de
l'actualité européenne cette semaine le
breakbeat theresa may a essuyé un
nouveau revers mardi la chambre des
communes a rejeté l'accord que la
première ministre avait négocié avec le
reste de l'europe durant de longs mois
le feuilleton du breakbeat va donc se
poursuivre avec le risque d'une sortie
sans accord un odile comme disent les
anglais bonjour gilles pargneaux
bonjour alors vous avez longtemps été
socialiste avant de rejoindre la
république en marche il ya un peu plus
d'un an maintenant mais vous siégez
toujours au groupe des socialistes et
démocrates
on va d'abord regarder ensemble ce qui
s'est passé mardi soir à la chambre des
communes avant d'en discuter avec vous
[Musique]
plus on doit reconnaître pour ceux qui
veulent vraiment mener à bien le brésil
sait si cet accord n'est pas conclu ce
soir
alors cette chambre prend le risque de
ne pas avoir de président du sco
[Applaudissements]
ôta odeurs
keystone le oui à droite 242 voix le nom
à gauche 391 voit donc le nom
l'emportent le non l'emporté et pour
femmes
je regrette profondément la décision
collège chambre a pris ce soir je suis
déterminé à mettre en oeuvre le choix
fait lors du référendum mais je suis
également convaincu que la meilleure
façon de quitter l'union et de le faire
avec un accord mais grâce à la décision
de la chance ce soir il y à des choix
qu'ils ne peuvent être réduits des
masques nofx
[Applaudissements]
c'est comme laisser le gouvernement a
une nouvelle fois été battu à une très
large majorité et il doit maintenant
accepter que son accord celui de la
première ministre est clairement mort et
n'a pas le soutien de cette chambre
[Musique]
gilles pargneaux ça semble inextricable
pour teresa mais on voit mal ce qui peut
empêcher à présent un odile une sortie
de l'europe sans accord pour le royaume
uni
oui donc comme l'a rappelé d'ailleurs
michel barnier
il faut s'y préparer mais ces derniers
temps les négociateurs pour l'union
européenne dans le cadre de ce brigitte
voulue par les britanniques donc il faut
aussi préparer
or tant que européen convaincu député de
la grande circonscription nord ouest
comprenant les hôtes france et la
normandie
le no deal est une catastrophe pour la
france pour l'europe et pour nos deux
régions
c'est lose lose 1re perdant perdant
parce que à no deal aurait des
conséquences très dure vis-à-vis de la
pêche non seulement pour les eaux de
france mais aussi pour la normandie et
l'agriculture est d'ailleurs la première
industrie qui sera impacté
malheureusement par anodine c'est
l'industrie automobile on sait que cette
industrie automobile est très présente
dans une région comme la région ou de
france 2 6 millions d'habitants alors
justement la france est elle prête à
faire face à un odile on va voir ce que
la france a préparé et on va voir si
c'est efficace
[Musique]
leur avenir dépend de l'issue du
breakbeat dans les hauts de france les
pêcheurs réalise près de 75% de leur
capture dans les eaux britanniques en
cas de brick site sans accord ils ne
pourront plus y jeter leurs filets vous
coupez la manche en deux vous rabattez
toute la flottille européenne dans ce
qui reste de la manche
c'est une catastrophe d'abord écologique
économique c'est ce sera ingérable sera
limite la bataille navale aussi avec les
autres nations ça va être compliqué
socialement avec les belges et les
hollandais sais pas comment ça va se
passer
ça va être la guerre je pense au delà de
la pêche il y à l'enjeu des marchandises
et des voyageurs en cas de bris exit dur
la france rétablira les contrôles aux
frontières
une perspective qui inquiète les
douaniers qui ont entamé une grève du
zèle avec le break six de ces deux
nouvelles missions qui vont qui vont
arriver et le risque si on n'y vais pas
aller si on n'y met pas les moyens c'est
qu'on va avoir des files de camions
encore plus grandes que celles qu'on a
aujourd'hui
pour éviter ces files de camions les
différents ports français ont prévu des
aires de stockage
mais la vraie question est celle des
effectifs de douaniers dans les ports
les gares et les aéroports
plus de 700 postes supplémentaires ont
été créées les effectifs douaniers sont
arrivés c'est pas simplement des
annonces budgétaires ils sont formées
parfois été formé pour la moitié d'entre
eux plus la moitié d'entre eux dans les
écoles de tourcoing de la rochelle
recruter parfois sans concours
pour aller plus vite on est prêt aux
briques site dès demain si j'ose dire
en revanche ce que nous attendons c'est
désormais la décision britannique
si l'état français se dit prêt qu'en est
il des milieux économiques
il y a quelques mois gérald darmanin
estimé que les entreprises françaises
n'étaient pas prêtes à faire face au
brésil
je suis très inquiet de la façon dont
les entreprises françaises s'intéressent
à ce sujet c'est grosso modo le bris si
tu ne peux pas arriver je sais ce que je
comprends du monde des affaires français
j'ai l'impression pour la première fois
si j'ose dire dans la vie n'est ni ce
que l'administration est prête avant le
monde de l'entreprise en cas de brick
site dur la france fait partie des pays
européens qui seront les plus touchés
derrière l'allemagne et les pays bas
le rétablissement de barrières
douanières lui ferait perdre 3 milliards
d'euros d'exportations par an
[Musique]
gilles pargneaux va prendre des sujets
un par un en cas de brick site dur ya
d'abord la question du rétablissement
des contrôles aux frontières est ce que
les ports et les aéroports français sont
prêts aujourd'hui c'est en cours vous
savez que le premier ministre a à
développer un plan d'aménagement des
ports de calais et de dunkerque eux
permettant ainsi de répondre mais des
allemands des aménagements
d'infrastructures de répondre à cette
demande
c'est un risque que ce soit que ce soit
millions d'euros qui sont proposées par
le gouvernement français à paris ce que
ce soit une paralysie du tracé entre les
îlots faire des aménagements de parkings
permettant ainsi de répondre à cet
afflux est assez files d'attentes qui
nécessairement seront présentes
les douaniers de leur côté disent qu'ils
sont pas assez nombreux malgré les
créations sont prévoit l'affectation de
700 douaniers supplémentaires pour
pouvoir répondre à ce nouveau travail
puisque il n'y aura plus la libre
circulation des personnes des biens des
marchandises entre le royaume uni et la
france
alors vous êtes vice président de la
commission environnement qui s'occupe
aussi toutes les questions de sécurité
un sanitaire alimentaire est ce qu a pas
un risque en cas de nos deals que le
royaume uni deviennent un peu la porte
d'entrée pour tout le reste du monde
vers l'europe pour contourner les normes
de sécurité c'est évidemment alimentaire
bien évidemment que c'est un risque est
un risque et nous sommes en train de
construire cette politique alimentaire à
l'échelle de l'union européenne
donc ce no deal cette indépendance
britannique pour être préjudiciable pour
ce travail pour protéger les européennes
les européens en matière alimentaire que
nous sommes en train d'entreprendre
bien évidemment que c'est un risque sauf
que ce no deal peut intervenir là dans
quelques jours quelques semaines à peine
on fera comment j'espère que les
britanniques ne veut pas aller jusqu'au
bout de cette catastrophe puisque on le
sait c'est trois points de pib en moins
de pouvoir d'achat en moins pour les
britanniques
c'est quasiment 1% de pouvoir d'achat en
moins pour les européens donc j'espère
que raison garder sera finalement
présente au bout du compte
alors viens de le voir dans ce reportage
ya la question des pêcheurs français y
sont très inquiétants des raisons d'être
inquiet parce que beaucoup d'entre eux
réalisent une grande partie de leur
capture dans les eaux britanniques et 6
s'il ya un mode ils n'auront plus le
droit de pêcher
qu'est ce qui peut être fait comme je
voulais pour les aider pour aujourd'hui
on est à 50 % de captures sur des eaux
territoriales anglaise pour les pêcheurs
normands 75%
ça a été dit dans le reportage pour les
pêcheurs
de la région hôte france ça pourrait
être la disparition de la pêche
française est en sorte s'ils nous disent
il ya que nous puissions tout de suite
avoir un accord bilatéral entre le
royaume uni et la france pour permettre
à nos pêcheurs des hauts de france et de
normandie de continuer à pêcher sur les
hits des eaux territoriales anglaise on
a entendu aussi ce message d' alerte qui
avait lancé gérald darmanin c'était fin
novembre à l'assemblée nationale disant
attention les entreprises françaises ne
prennent pas au sérieux cette question
du brésil elles ne sont pas prêtes
est ce que le message a été entendu à ce
que le retard a été rattrapé depuis
l'excédent de la balance commerciale en
faveur vers le royaume uni pour la
région de france et de 2 milliards
d'euros
voyez bien que c'est beaucoup donc les
décideurs économiques des régions
normandie haute france que j'ai
rencontrés depuis ce mode de novembre
mais cette déclaration du ministre
ils se mobilisent ils se sont mobilisés
j'étais il ya quelques semaines au sein
du comité grand lille 2 à lille dans la
métropole lilloise et on voit bien qu'il
ya la nécessité pour qu'il y ait cette
mobilisation au cas où il y aurait ce
d'autils alors il ya un homme qui est
appris la lumière si l'on peut dire dans
le cas des négociations du président
c'est michel barnier le négociateur en
chef pour les européens
son travail est saluée par tous
aujourd'hui il ferait un bon président
de la commission européenne à michel
barnier a été un négociateur hors pair
il a une connaissance de l'union
européenne et c'est un diplomate
et donc
je ne sais si il a envie d'être
président de la commission européenne
met en avant pas doté ce canton fils
tour de celles et de ceux qui pourraient
prendre cette présidence
ap les élections du 26 mai il fait
partie de ceux de la short list comme on
dit et de ce qui pourrait assurer cette
présidence vous souhaiterez soit
candidat à avoir un président de la
future commission avec un futur
parlement européen qui puisse être
conforme à mes aspirations vous à dire
avoir une europe qui protège mais une
europe aussi qui doit permettre de
s'affirmer dans le concert international
michel barnier à l'évidence correspond à
ses critères bien évident merci avoue
gilles pargneaux d'être venu sur le
plateau d' europe hebdo on va reprendre
à présent notre tour d'europe entamé la
semaine dernière
[Musique]
al'approche des élections européennes on
s'intéresse aujourd'hui à l'espagne on
va jeter un oeil d'abord à sa carte
d'identité si l'on peut dire le pays
compte 46 millions d'habitants son
économie représente 8 4% du pib européen
l'espagne a intégré l'union européenne
en 1986 elle a actuellement 54 députés
européens il en aura 59 dans la future
assemblée et vous le voyez c'est une
monarchie avec comme roy felipe 6 et
comme chef du gouvernement le socialiste
pedro sanchez le pré le pays se prépare
à quatre scrutins différents il ya bien
sûr les européennes
le 26 mai mais également les élections
législatives le 28 avril et enfin des
élections régionales et municipales qui
se prépare en parallèle le parti
socialiste au pouvoir espère être réélue
mais le paysage politique espagnole est
en pleine recomposition avec notamment
l'émergence de l'extrême droite
on en parle avec nos invités après ce
reportage en espagne de clément
perreault
[Musique]
qui a dit que le socialisme ne fait plus
recette en europe
ce meeting à ciudad real au sud de
madrid affiche complet la moitié des
participants ne pourront pas entrer
alors qu'un marathon électoral se
profile en espagne le peso et parti
socialiste ouvrier espagnol fait la
course en tête dans les sondages
nous sommes en train de retrouver
l'espoir et nous voulons en finir avec
les coupes sociales qui ont suffisamment
duré ce peuple a besoin de services à la
population que l'attention soit vraiment
porté aux citoyens business ça suffit
priorité aux personnes face à une ultra
droite décomplexée qui ne se cache pas
nous avons besoin en espagne en europe
d'un parti socialiste fort
ce retour en grâce socialiste doit
beaucoup au leader du parti et actuel
président du gouvernement pedro sanchez
la foule voient en lui le sauveur de la
gauche
il vient de gouverner neuf mois sans
majorité
mais il en a profité pour lancer
quelques réformes progressistes il fait
campagne sur les valeurs et l'affectif
nous défendons les valeurs de solidarité
de fraternité de respect de tolérance et
de diversité
nous refusons de considérer la société
comme un bloc uniforme journée
internationale des femmes à madrid un
terrain favorable pour cette campagne
sur les valeurs de la gauche
dans les cortèges féministe les membres
du gouvernement sont dans leurs aînés je
vous à dire aux français votre
déclaration des droits de l'homme de
1789 quand vous parlez de liberté
d'égalité et de fraternité
et bien aujourd'hui nous sommes là pour
être solidaire de ses valeurs solidaires
pour les droits de l'homme et l'égalité
réelle entre les hommes
pour gagner la gauche espagnole devra
passer par une alliance entre les
socialistes et podemos le parti issu des
indignés elle pourrait alors constituer
un contrepoids dans une europe où
triomphent les libéraux et les
conservateurs
il y à une droite très puissante en
europe mais en espagne elle va avoir
plus de mal à gouverner parce que nous
sommes des combattants la femme en
espagne tire souvent la charrette et je
pense que nous pouvons être un moteur
pour le reste de l'europe
trois cent cinquante mille participants
pour cette manifestation
une démonstration de force en réponse à
celle ci la droite espagnole rassemblés
le 10 février dernier
cette foule l'a chauffé à blanc par les
troubles en catalogne demandait elle la
démission de pedro sanchez
accusé de laxisme vis-à-vis des
indépendantistes l'espagne est descendu
sur les places et dans les rues devra
aussi se rendre dans les urnes pour
censurer le gouvernement est condamné ce
qui se passe dans le pays
enfin aujourd'hui commence la reconquête
des espagnols qui ont dit basta passe
pas dans la manifestation ou aux côtés
des conservateurs du partido popular et
des libéraux dessus
annonce un autre parti vox c'est la
première formation d'extrême droite
structuré depuis franco elle a surgi en
capitalisant sur la question catalan
l'enjeu c'est de récupérer notre
démocratie notre souveraineté et notre
parole brandissaient les drapeaux sans
peur de rien ni personne
vive le roi et vive l'espagne
mais pour la droite se rassembler sur la
question catalan est une chose le faire
sur l'europe en est une autre
vox est un parti eurosceptique qui se
réclame de donald trump ciudadanos est
lui proche dans marche
nous sommes des libéraux
nous sommes proches dans marche avec qui
nous collaborons sur des questions
européennes
récemment nous avons appuyé la lettre
ouverte écrite par makoun aux européens
nous approuvons l'idéologie et les
propositions dans marche et nous sommes
en collaboration avec leur équipe
la capacité des blocs de droite et de
gauche à rassembler leurs forces sera la
clé de ces élections
les difficultés des partis espagnols à
former des majorités ont plongé le pays
dans une crise politique
qui dure depuis maintenant trois ans
[Musique]
voilà donc pour ce reportage que où de
nombreux sujets de discussion avec moi
pour en parler henrique calbet chomon
bonjour vous eurodéputé espagnol membre
du groupe à elle d eux le centre droit
libéral ici au parlement européen de
strasbourg est également à mes côtés
juan fernando lopez aguilar bonjour
bonjour vous êtes eurodéputé espagnol
est également membre du parti socialiste
ancien ministre de la justice d'euros
c'est luis zapatero je commence par vous
on vient de le voir dans ce reportage ya
ces élections législatives qui court
circuite un peu la campagne des
européennes et qu'il éclipse est ce que
c'est pas un problème
au contraire je crois que ça va stimuler
la participation
ah oui ça c'est ça c'est un opéra
biberon à tous et à toutes
durenque à la situation extrêmement
volatil ce moment intéressant mais il
faut se dépêcher parce qu'il y aura les
élections législatives 28 avril il y
aura les élections locales régionales et
les européens
26 mai et il y a beaucoup en échange il
ya beaucoup en jeu
l'enjeu c'est énorme je crois que les
des filles c'est plutôt existentielle et
parce que il y à une polarisation
extrême dans ces moments là dans la
politique espagnole et il ya
l'opportunité de valider les efforts qui
ont été jouées par les gouvernements
espagnols présidée par à peine ressentir
les socialistes pedro sanchez pour
recomposer la alternative progressiste
dont la droite la plus décomplexée et
plus agressif que n'a jamais connu
depuis la mort de franco alors on va
parler des élections législatives dans
un instant mais d'abord quand même un
mot de ces élections européennes et du
sentiment européen en espagne
l'europe elle a longtemps été perçu
positivement par les espagnols comme et
dans le pays à se développer à s'ouvrir
au monde après les années du franquisme
aujourd'hui on voit l'émergence de ce
parti d'extrême droite vox qui n'est pas
forcément très pro européens
comment vous l'expliquez alors il ya
beaucoup de questions dans ce que vous
avez dit
d'abord je discuterai cette assignation
d'extrême droite à vox
secundo il y a une particularité
espagnole qu'il est très difficile de
transmettre en europe qui est que et là
je reprends le mot existentielle de
notes de ministre en effet le 28 avril
ce sont des élections qui vont à
l'essentiel avec l'existant ciel parce
qu'on voit que ce sont les législatives
lewis est à dire juste avant les
européennes et pour l'instant les
européens la parle même pas et c'est
est-ce que l'espagne va continuer à
exister en tout cas comme une société de
citoyens égaux libre et solidaire
ou est-ce que l'espagne va se fragmenter
avec des petits coups d'état la
confédération assume et des fédérations
asymétrique c'est là qu'on va jouer
alors ça c'est ça commençait en effet
même si on a voulu les touchés par tous
les gouvernements des dernières 25
années
ça commence à affleurer et alors là
quand on a besoin de l'europe
il arrive des choses assez
lamentable comme par exemple
l'inexistence d'une robe judiciaire où
les allemands se permettent de ne pas
appliquer attention je ne dis pas
d'interpréter de ne pas appliquer et
c'est à dire de faire un fraudeur de loi
en appliquant leurs ordres alors ça ça
commence à enquiquiner les espagnols
n'ont de 10 rebonds alors qu'est-ce que
qu'est ce que c'est que ça alors pour là
et c'était très bien non mais pour les
problèmes financiers d'accord ils
viennent mais c'est à base de notre
austérité mais quand on a besoin d'eux
d'une justice européenne d'une
solidarité pour un pays qu'il faut joue
son existence et celle de l'europe parce
que si par la catalogne ont commencé à
introduire et le racisme et le
séparatisme en europe c'est pas fini
alors il y a un certain mouvement de
recettes d'is isme ou de resto mais
l'europe l'espagne actuellement est
encore majoritairement pour vous
partager ce point de vue ou est ce que
le sentiment pro-européen est en train
de s'effriter lentement en espagne il y
avait bien sûr un changement
générationnel sociologique et même
politique
il ya un changement il était une fois
l'espagne était héros un dossier est
noyée de ma génération je suis
professeur d'université et je preuve
dans mon expérience mon expérience
universitaire que la jeunesse maintenant
en espagne est plutôt eurosceptiques
compact comme partout et il y a des bons
raison ou l'être parce qu' il y ait une
période prolongée dans ce terreau était
il ya eu des coupes
il y avait des politiques antisociales
il ya eu des inégalités et que ça se
perd et qui ont enragé la génération de
la plus jeune mais en tout cas l'espagne
reste oui européen et - européiste mais
je dois dire que normalement
historiquement les jeux politiques
divisés
la lutte politique où droite et gauche
dans une façon très claire maintenant il
y a encore un facteur nationale
d'identité nationale et c'est la
conséquence de l'intégration de la
question canal
cette question qui dérange elle occupe
la une de votre doigt tous les jours on
doit faire des efforts pour expliquer la
question catalan sûrement et derrière
dès l'émergence de l'extrême droite
alors on va expliquer à nos donateurs
pourquoi c'est qu'il ya un procès qui
fait la une de vos journaux en ce moment
le procès des douze leader
indépendantiste catalan accusés de
rébellion c'est une accusation très
lourde dans le droit pénal espagnol ils
encourent des peines de plusieurs
dizaines d'années de prison pour
certains près de trente ans je crois et
il se trouve que vox s'est porté partie
civile et utilise ce procès comme une
tribune politique
qu'est ce qui peut être fait face à ça
pour contrebalancer en quelque sorte
est-ce que ça crée un déséquilibre dans
le débat politique il ne faut pas que je
sois ministre la solution sirh ministre
agisse pour dire qu'il y ait fait
confiance au système judiciaire espagnol
la cour suprême espagnole a une
indépendance assurée par la loi et par
la constitution
et ça c'est sûr que tous les accusés
j'ai eu un droit à la défense endroit
tous les gentils des procédures des
processus pénal et mais en tout cas la
dernière parole
et à la cour suprême des points de vue
juridique des points de vie politique ça
c'est sûr que les gouvernements
nationalistes indépendantistes de la
catalogne a pratiqué rupture unilatérale
des religieux il a violé la constitution
il a violé les statuts de l'autonomie
catalane et ça c'est sûr qu aucune étape
des droits peut réciter une violation
des sérères l'existentiel c réation
essaie de rectifier les victimes annonce
on a compris que vous êtes très opposés
aux indépendantistes de toute forme
d'ingérence et moi je suis
indépendantiste moi même ah oui par
exemple le chien des pénaltys pour la
guyane française il n'y a pas
d'indépendance et son espagne il y a des
sécessionnistes
c'est très différent parce que le
sécessionnisme est absolument illégale
et moral et ça ça arrive à l'espagne
comme ça arriver aux états unis avec le
général lee
maintenant moi j'ai défendu
l'indépendance de l'algérie je défends
celle de la guyane et c'est alors ne
payant pas les valeurs mais vous avez
cité que le procès non parce que ce
procès il établit non vous vous citer
comme disait le général de gaulle
l'écumé de la vague
ce qu'il y a eu c'est un coup d'état un
coup d'état au ralenti et c'est un
ancien ministre socialiste a mis à mort
alfonso guerra qui à kamal al antaki à
inventer c'est ça qui est important
c'est que en espagne ça fait 25 ans que
le gouvernement de toutes sortes de
toutes sortes les gouvernements de
toutes sortes on laisser impunément
s'installer une réalité parallèle de
coup d'état
c'est ça qui est grave après des
ressources parce que vos collègues une
part de responsabilité dans la situation
d'aujourd'hui pendant ses années de
gouvernements certainement qu'est ce que
vous répondez face à ces accusations de
laxisme sur cette question catalan
on peut faire des rétroactions dans
l'histoire de si loin que vous voulez
mais ça aucune chance la vérité c'est
qu'il y a eu une période dans lesquels
les gouvernements socialistes de la
catalogne a rompu complètement et ont
naturellement la constitution et le
statut d'autonomie de la catalogne et
étaient avertis et dans notre code pénal
que c'est un corps pénale parfaitement
démocratique là des souris cela des
souris sens aux décisions des cours de
justice c'est un délit l'investissement
des l'argent public pour faire pour
poursuivre un objectif illégal c'est un
délit et bien sûr et bien sûr la
violation des règles juridiques
administratifs pour poursuivre des
filles des femmes et des sites c'est
aussi un raid élite je voudrais qu'on
évoque comme toutes ces mesures prises
pendant les neuf mois de gouvernement
socialistes mesure très social
il ya la hausse du salaire minimum les
retraites à nouveau indexés sur
l'inflation un congé paternité de 112
jours d'ici à 2021 une politique
d'accueil assez généreux généreuse
vis-à-vis des réfugiés on a le sentiment
qu après les années de rigueur et les
espagnols plébiscitent cette politique
sociale qu'ils ont besoin de cela nous
avons besoin de politiques sociales et
ont besoin de se récupérer de la crise
hélas ils vont pas pouvoir le faire
et alors là le gouvernement pedro
sanchez est là et là ya pas de chance
mais il arrive au début de la suivante
crise alors le problème de toutes ces
mesures qui peuvent être certaines sont
assez loufoques comme par exemple
augmenter le salaire minimum 1 22% d'un
coup moi je suis pour mais qu'il est
assez bas en espagne et qui est dit oui
et le reste il est en très près ce que
des gens suis très contente d'appliquer
les mesures sociales de façon anticipée
que nous sommes en train de décider sur
parlement comme par exemple la garantie
d des libéraux etc
le problème c'est en ce moment comment
on va financer cela c'est ça le problème
vous avez dit la vérité mais pour
compléter il faut valider cet effort
pour relancer la politique sociale en
espagne pour que vous parlez
l'égalité des droits et d'opportunités
après les coupes kroell qui ont été
pratiquées sans concession par le
gouvernement populaire pour combien
d'années avec la majorité absolue
tous les abus des meilleurs intérêts des
petits populaire et pour faire ça il
faut valider mais non dans un dispositif
la majorité parlementaire qu'il a fait
manquer pour les renouvellements ou
pedro sans qui ce projet d'avenir
merci moi merci beaucoup et on espère
également qu'une pour le pays aucune
majorité nette se dégagera de ces
élections sont les troisièmes élections
législatives en à peine trois ans pour
le pays
l'émission touche à sa fin merci
messieurs d'être venu dans europe hebdo
pour nous parler de l'espagne la semaine
prochaine il sera question de la grèce
d'ici là portez vous bien
[Musique]
bras